[Musique]
bonjour mesdames merci d'être ici pour
une envie de lecture vous allez nous
présenter un livre coup de coeur et vous
allez nous donner envie de le lire
oui c'est lyon qui devra essayer on va
faire le maximum
alors présenté vous madame qui est voir
moi je suis laetitia cambou je travaille
à la médiathèque 17 mar aujourd'hui je
vais vous proposer un autre
vous allez nous proposer un livre un bon
gars un manga alors à manquer qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
donc c'est une bande dessinée japonaise
oui donc à la particularité de cette
fois-ci droite et gauche d'accord et
donc c'est un titre qui me tient à coeur
parce qu'en fait la série a fêté ses 20
ans l'année dernière donc je vous
parlais de 4,14 acura qui regardent
harcèlement du lean du mans bat
l'angleterre c'est le nom du manga donc
ces cartes captor sakura clear arc
je savais que j'allais me trompe
l'établir pierre les arrêts dont c'est
du studio clamp donc le studio clamp en
fait c'est un regroupement de quatre
femmes qui ont créé ce manga d'habitude
mon gars c'est plutôt un travail
solitaire mais là ils sont quatre à
travailler dessus et donc on retrouve
donc une jeune fille qui a commencé sa
carrière il ya vingt ans à peu près donc
cette fois ci à rentrer au collège en
cinquième
donc au collège de sages ils s'appellent
sa cour à l'essai pour qui la nation et
puis ça se passe au japon
ah oui les quarts voilà donc elle
s'appelle sakurai sportive par contre
elle n'aime pas vraiment les batte et
donc dans sa vie privée elle a des ailes
à des pouvoirs
donc elle a acquis dans la première
série est là dans cette seconde série
elle revient elle a toujours ses
pouvoirs magiques
elles sont certes très peu mais pour une
raison inconnue elle les perd
en tout cas le père les objets qui
permettent de s'en servir donc d'exercer
ses pouvoirs qui dit cathy dubois qui
sont des cartes magiques mais il fait
qui aurait perdu ça laguait voilà donc
on va essayer de récupérer un peu à peu
ses pouvoirs elle fait beaucoup de rêves
qui sont très bonne histoire l a
accompagnée d'une petite structure toute
mignonne qui s'appelle kg
qui parle avec le japon lire l accent du
canto qu'en fait ce serait l'accent
marseillais pour les français du sud du
japon à la ca sud du japon mais voilà et
elle va essayer de récupérer toute sa
magie sachant qu'elle est menacée par
une organisation secrète assez
dangereuse mais ça reste un an gâterait
millions dont qui fleure qui sauf entre
le quotidien de sakura qui aime faire la
cuisine qui aime faire plaisir à ses
proches et dont toute sa récupération de
pouvoir et c'est comprendre qu'il à
bonas en fait c'est là se livrent à ce
manga il est destiné à quel public car
c'est un public je sais tout public
tsonga par le calage alors n'importe
quel jeu très bien partir de 7 ans
jusqu'à et donc ça c'est un épisode
passé c'est le début d'une série
genève est lâchée sur tout le monde
vieillit bon alors voilà le logiciel
mais je sais pas encore ce que la série
toujours en cours de publication
très bien on peut déjà lire sur villard
de gala très bien m'écouter merci les
titien raphaël
dites moi quel est votre coup de coeur
alors alors mon coup de coeur c'est le
livre de harper lee ne tirez pas sur
l'oiseau moqueur donc c'est un roman je
pense que c'est un des livres préférés
de tous les temps
voilà je sais pas si j'ai dû le lire une
dizaine de fois donc en fait sorti en
poche il est sorti en poche le tout à
fait donc l'histoire en fête se déroule
dans une petite ville de l'alabama des
années 30
la narratrice est une petite fille scout
finch et donc dont le père est avocat
l'intrigué principale c'est que le papa
avocat qui est un homme intègre avec des
valeurs et un une envie de justice doit
défendre un homme noir accusé d'avoir
violé une femme blanche de la ville et
on est en pleine ségrégation dans le sud
des états unis et on le voit à travers
les yeux d'enfant de cette petite fille
de 7 ans très espiègle qui fait les 400
coups avec son meilleur ami et son grand
frère et qui s'invente des histoires
donc on découvre à la fois des
personnages assez assez pittoresque
aussi du village un voisin assez
énigmatique qui leur fait très très peur
et elle va peu à peu va sortir de
l'innocence en envoyant la lutte de son
père face à l'injustice au défendre cet
homme de cet homme injustement accusés
c'est très très bien écrit c'est très
touchant
ça ça a du souffle c'est magnifique et
et c'était le seul livre d'art peur
ligue l'a écrit dans les années 60 est
en fait il n'y avait aucun autre romande
elle qui n'est paru depuis jusqu'à
jusqu'à deux ans avant il ya devait
juste avant sa mort connaissait il ya eu
quand vous l'avez tout lu ben c'est vrai
qu'on attendait de fiches tous et toutes
qu'elles sortent quelque chose qui gagne
en faisant surtout depuis les années 60
juncker c'est le cas maintenant et alors
du coup à l'assortiment allées dallées
décédé il ya deux ans mais juste juste
avant de décéder son deuxième livre
qu'elle avait écrit finalement avant ne
tirez pas sur l'oiseau moqueur et
sorties et ses vagues et les postes une
sentinelle pour croire que tout ce qui
vous a pris aussi qui me plaît aussi
c'est la suite c'est la suite mais elle
avait écrit onfray allègre et la suite
on pouvait ouais elle avait écrit
l'histoire de cette petite fille qui est
devenu un jeune adulte et
et de sa famille nos qu'éventuellement
pourquoi ces les suivront celles des
deux salariés après bah c'est fini après
c'est fini mal n'avait fait que deux
livres
elle n'a écrit que de livrer là était
aussi connu parce qu'elle était l'une
des meilleures amies de truman capote et
elle l'a elle a assisté notamment dans
son enquête sur pour écrire de sang
froid voilà et d'ailleurs c'est le
personnage du petit garçon de son
meilleur ami dans le livre ne tirez pas
sur l'oiseau moqueur et où grandement
inspiré de son ami truman capote et
angers bat et goûter merci merci
beaucoup
alors dites moi tout alors moi je vais
vous présenter un coup de coeur très
personnel qui s'avère un la grèce et les
sept chevreaux de vaud la ligne guépard
a illustré par martine bourg aux
éditions didier jeunesse
en fait c'est une histoire que je
raconte très souvent pendant les
animations à la médiathèque cas ce que
vous racontez des histoires aux enfants
tout à fait ça fait partie du métier de
bibliothécaire au bout et en fait c'est
un coot détourner du célèbre conte des
frères grimm le louer les sept chevrons
oui ça faisait quelque chose tout à fait
mais c'est la version libanaise vont du
compte ou en fait on a
bal à la maman chèvres qui va chaque
jour chercher à manger pour ces petits
de l'herbe verte dans le pré
elle met en garde ces enfants contre
l'eau grèce qui pourrait venir les
manger oui à la place du loup on a une
ogresse c'est çà et là on peut voir
peut-être la nes de la grèce toujours
servir l'autre à ce joli comme des
saucisses voilà le glace ah oui d'accord
là est en fait au lieu de deux la patte
blanche
oui qu'on passe à la porte là c'est là
que à passer par la chatière d'accord
donc forcément l'ogresse vient frapper à
la porte
elle passera que par la chatière mais
qui est restée sèche ou donc pas douce
et lisse comme la maman un chèvre là que
la maman shahzad quel fils chez la
coiffeuse grèce tout à fait et fini elle
file chez la coiffeuse pour le film
d'esprit tout à fait pour voilà ce faire
peignée elle arrive à rentrer dans la
maison elle gop tous les petits sauf le
petit dernier qui prévient forcément sa
maman quand quand elle revient et la
maman elle n'est pas contente mais alors
pas contente du tout donc melbourne où
elle sa place
elle met ses cornes de faire à droite on
est dans l'univers traction alors là
c'est une bonne mère c'est gênant mais
raide mais ces cornes de faire elle file
chez l'ogresse et boum est là qu elle
lui ouvre le ventre et elle libère ses
petits et on fermin sur une image très
rigolotes ou en fait elle va laver ses
petits à la rivière elle aimait à sécher
soit au final mais le dessin est
vraiment original c'était vraiment
original c'est très beau et surtout le
texte en fait écrit par praline guépard
acquis une conteuse hors pair et très
accessible aux enfants à partir de 2 ans
et demi deux ans assez petit c'est ça
mais je raconte vraiment pour les heurts
du cloud 0 3 ans parce qu'en fait il ya
énormément de jeux avec les mots de
sonorités de musicalité ses écrits en
français s'est traduit ces écrits en
français
oui parce qu aurait alors comment ils
réagissent les petits elle va en fait
ils sont captivés
mais vraiment pas ce qu'il ya vraiment
des rimes des jeux de mots vraiment tous
les ingrédients pour un coot pour tout
petit et en même temps c'est une belle
manière de
pas de présenter un compte autre que
notre tradition occidentale
c'est vraiment super bien c'est même
chercher un livre à lire à des bébés
presque ça marche ok super annie avoue
oui je voulais juste rajouter que
praliné gay-para est en résidence depuis
trois ans c'est la troisième année à
guyancourt et donc vous intervenez
beaucoup dans l'est dans les quartiers
la mener des ateliers avec hédi ben
voilà donc l accueil écrire plusieurs
albums j'imagine mais voilà voilà
on a beaucoup beaucoup il vous plaît
tous autant oui j'adore très bien
m'écouter on va suivre cette piste alors
génial alors dites nous tout alors à
l'insep au monde avec quelque chose de
très différent de ce qui a été évoqué
précédemment donc il s'agit d'un livre
de kate tempest c'est une jeune auteure
vraiment jeunes auteurs à la une
trentaine d'années britannique et elle
est connue dans le milieu du rap parce
qu'elle elle est musicienne elle est
alors je sais plus comment d'y aller
elle chante et parle en même temps donc
je cela tient de slam c'est pas que du
slam c'est un rêve et elle et elle fait
des performances et elle est aussi
poétesse est là elle a récolté dès les
louanges notamment avec un grand prix
pour l'innovation de ceux de sa poésie
d'accord ce livre là en fait c'est un
vraiment un livre
contemporain livre de son temps un livre
moderne à la série s'appelle vous m'avez
ça s'appelle écoute la ville tombait
écoute la ville tombait voilà c'est un
très très beau livre je crois que c'est
son premier fils je pense pas je pense
que ces deuxièmes traduit en français je
sais pas si c'est le premier avait
révélé il est publié aux éditions
rivages où est une très très bonne
maison d'édition là c'est un livre où
elle va raconter le quotidien
d'habitants d'un quartier popu la faim
qui était populaire jusqu'il ya peu à
londres du grand londres donc pas très
loin de greenwich le au sud de londres
du londres civic center
et donc c'était un quartier populaire où
les habitants avaient des relations
entre eux et avec eux des petits
commerces avec le peuple bien évidemment
avec le centre commercial la gare les
buts de buts voilà et puis ce quartier
évidemment comme beaucoup de quartiers
évolué on est en face de boboïsation à
londres également et donc elle raconte
la vie de deux trois quatre cinq
personnages donc en fait et dessine
certains tableaux d'un des petits
tableaux peints qui petit à petit au fil
de l'histoire vont constituer une grande
histoire qui est leur histoire
donc on les voit
mal goupillé pour des trafics de drogue
on les voit aller au pub on les voit
faire du karaoké
on les voit surtout amassé un peu de
sous pour réaliser leur grand rêve
ils ont entre 17 et 30 ans les voit
évoluer dans le minervois aussi leurs
aînés qui sont aussi des intervenants
1dans hockey dans leur histoire et si
vraiment vous a passionné oui c'est
passionnant parce que c'est c'est
extrêmement rythmé c'est c'est un
univers que les gars il ya un souffle
aux ja c'est un univers qu'on connaît si
paris version britten à la voilà etc on
en entend la musique de du récit et
quand j'ai écouté parce que je
connaissais pas du tout et j'ai écouté
un cd et j'ai trouvé que c'était
identique
le rythme est vraiment il est donc la
meuse rappeuse et ma grand merci à
laurent bon on a du pain sur la planche
pour cet été pour pouvoir remplir nos
valises de livres grâce à vous merci
donc vous avez une actualité au mois de
juillet on entendit un petit mot ça
s'appelle partir en livres sont elles
partiront livre c'est surtout son compte
en tout 50 avec un moment phare le
dernier jour à laquelle en deux jours
tout à fait à la conversation 21 juillet
va se passer plein de choses y aura une
chasse aux trésors fonte et il y aura
une la conception en atelier de
conception d'une grande fresque avec une
illustratrice florissant val qui est
déjà intervenu avec nous et donc ça
s'est ouvert à ce rang c'est ouvert à
tous voilà mes aura dès lors il y aura
quoi en skis game et un bal à bla bla du
jeu alors comme on en reparle c'est pas
grave on regarde le mystère merci à
toutes celles ci à bientôt en voir
[Musique]